[Music]
you really get into a character when
you're doing it do these kind of roles
ever infiltrate your infiltrate your
dreams do you ever like feel like you're
playing this this part and a very
intense reality and then you start
dreaming about it in your real life to
be honest yeah with this this particular
show not yet but when I was on Breaking
Bad I was I would dream as Jesse all the
time I really would and not in a good
way we like a very violent scary yeah
what's scary way I mean I would dream as
if you know I'd wake up and I'd see Jane
there lying dead next to me oh my I try
to revive her and then I'd wake up out
of a nightmare and I go my god that was
a dream and I look over and it's Jane
again and it was just it was terrifying
or people running out for me with guns
it's great yeah that's so strange you
wake up and you think the rest of us
think oh that was just a dream and then
you think well it kind of was a dream
but I also did play that part right I
did actually have that experience with
sort of yeah yeah because I I truly you
know as an actor you try and force
yourself to believe the situations are
truly happening to you as the character
and so I was just so in that guy's skin
for so many years and so it just kind of
took over
you